Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two lifelong
friends talk about life
for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the
roundtable of dim lighting,
we're having a little listening party.
Congratulations, Rhett!
It's finally happened.
Your freaking album is out!
I mean, not when we're recording this,
but yes, when you're listening.
I'm in celebration mode.
James and the Shame, Rhett's alter ego,
where he plays music that is sincerely
sentimentized and sincerely great.
Oh, thanks, man.
It's my pleasure to sit here
and listen to it with you
and kinda talk through
each song, you know?
Yeah, this is like a listening party.
I'm gonna take, you know,
a journalistic approach at times.
Okay, NPR kinda thing?
I have a notepad here-
Well, that's intimidating.
Whereas I'm going to jot,
maybe make some jottings
that then will lead to you
exposing the truth behind-
Whoa.
Behind these songs.
But also-
I just got all the music
off of a royalty free site
and just sing over it?
You want me to admit that finally?
What if-
Okay, up first. Go for it.
That would be hilarious.
Again, the album is "Human Overboard".
The whole album is out now
wherever you listen to your music.
What we're gonna be doing is
listening to all 11 tracks
in album order.
As you're listening to this,
you're not gonna hear the full track,
'cause we're not gonna
just play the full song,
for every single song.
We're gonna listen to the full song.
So, we might reference something
that is in one of the full
songs that you didn't hear
because we're gonna play
like a portion of the song
to give you the feel and the vibe
so you can listen to the
album on your own time.
So that's what we'll do.
I'm actually gonna take these out
'cause I'm actually not
listening to anything right now
and it makes my voice sound weird.
Yeah, I already had to do that.
I'm gonna do what they used
to do in the old movies
and I'm gonna do the credits first.
'Cause I don't wanna just put
the people that I wanna think at the end,
and you're just like,
"I've heard the whole
album and then I'm done."
And so you might wanna fast,
I mean, if you decide
you wanna fast-forward-
Play fast-forward through it?
No, I'm saying you might decide
that you wanna fast-forward, but don't.
Because one of the coolest
things about this whole project
has been the collaborative nature
of it coming to fruition
and being what it is.
You know, I had a lot of people
who made me sound the way that I sound
and shaped these songs and
shaped the whole project
that I collaborated with
on different parts of it,
so I wanna just start by thanking them.
Do you have a list?
I do.
First of all, I wanna just start with-
Now you haven't won an
award, I just wanna clarify.
Yeah, no, I haven't.
Maybe you will.
Well, okay. What kind of award?
I'm just saying, typically
you thank people-
The Daily Record is gonna
be, "Best album of the year
from a guy who used to have
a studio in Lillington."
Yeah, you could get
a Chamber of Commerce award
at least for this thing.
No, I'm just saying these are the people
who made this project what it is.
Shout 'em out, man.
So, first of all, the person
who played the biggest role,
Derek Fuhrmann, my producer,
who of course we got to know-
I love me some Derek.
We got to know through
Britain, Link's cousin,
because he was recording
some stuff with him
and he's done some stuff
from the Mythical Society,
for, you know, our collabs
that we do over there
at the vinyl that we do.
And, you know, the reason I decided to go
with Derek on this project
isn't because he had never
done any country or folk music,
he's a pop guy,
but because he is so committed
to making things work
and he was so committed
to learning the process.
And, like, he told me
multiple things like,
"I'm learning so much
about this type of music,"
you know, as we make these songs.
And, again, the way that it worked
is I would write the lyrics and the music,
basically me and a guitar,
singing to a certain beat, that bpm.
That's beat per minute.
Yeah, and I would send him that
and that is the backbone of
everything that he then create.
If it was one beat per
minute, that would be slow.
Sorry, go ahead.
That's whale music.
But then he would kinda send back,
because, again, I have another job,
actually several other jobs
that I do here at Mythical.
So, this has been a
side project and a hobby
so I haven't been able
to devote the kinda time
that typically people
devote to this kinda thing.
So, I was send him these demos
and then he would come
back with, like, he's like,
"Hey, here's what I'm
thinking about the baseline.
This is kinda what I'm
hearing in a drum groove,"
kinda thing that then we would
then send off to other people
to add their pieces.
It was like so collaborative
and so many steps
to finally get to the final song.
But he was the one that
was guiding that process
to kinda be like, "Here's what,"
he would send me a bunch of
options and he would send me,
but really it was his ear and his instinct
with these different
musicians that he hired
that made these songs go
from a guy playing something on a guitar
to what you end up hearing on the album.
And he was just so intimately involved
in making it what it is.
So, I just wanted to start,
big thanks to Derek Fuhrmann.
You would be lucky to
have him as a producer
on your project.
He stays very busy but-
You know, if you've not experienced it,
sometimes it's hard.
Well, in hip hop it's actually, you know,
a lot more credit is given to producers.
But, like, growing up listening to music,
I really didn't think
about the producer's role.
And so everything you just described
is not necessarily something
that is just because of your situation
and all the different directions
that you've been pulled in
that you needed to, like,
give it over to Derek or something,
I think you're describing
what a good producer does,
which is, you know,
something that I didn't
appreciate at first
and, like, helping
bring shape and cohesion
and specific direction to songs
that are in their rawest form, you know?
A producer can make or
break a song entirely
with where he sees it.
A great producer is
also a musical director,
somebody who's like, "Hey,
let's try that again,"
and, "Give me a little bit more softness,"
or, "Give me a little bit
more emotion in that,"
or, you know, even a couple of times,
this didn't happen on every song,
but there were a couple of
songs where he was like,
"Ah, the phrasing of that
part is kinda bumping me,"
and we would sit there and we
would try to figure out like,
"Oh, I'm gonna use this syllable.
I'm gonna use this word here,"
and, like, locking it in
so there's not things that
bump you throughout the album.
So, he was integral in that process.
Another person that did
so much, Alex Strahle.
The first time I talked about Alex,
when we talked about "Believe Me",
I mispronounced his last name.
I think I said Strohl. Strahle.
So, Alex is just a, he's a
multi-instrumentalist musician
here in California, in Los Angeles,
who's in a couple of bands,
but he's also kind of
a session guitar guy.
And Derek knew him.
You know, originally, with so much,
like, we wanted to do pedal steel,
we wanted to do obviously,
like, country sounding guitar in places,
we wanted banjo, we wanted mandolin.
Alex did all of that.
So, originally it was gonna be like,
Derek was like, "I gotta
have to talk to some contacts
to get some Nashville guys
to do these authentic country parts."
And then he didn't have
any luck with that,
but he is like, "Hey, I
know a guy in Pasadena.
Alex Strahle."
He's got all these old
guitars and old instruments.
Like, the pedal steel
is a 1946 instrument.
Wow.
That's not even a pedal steel.
It's a multi-cord.
It is like a predecessor to a pedal steel-
Really?
That he engineered to be able to,
because basically the way the multi-cord,
you would hit a pedal and
it changes the whole cord
that's being played, right?
He found a way to make it where he can,
he, like, does all this,
he manipulates all these
instruments and stuff
and he basically engineered this thing
to make it into a pedal steel.
But that's not technically
what you would see
as a lap pedal steel.
Oh, a pedal steel.
You play the cords with your feet?
With your feet. A pedal.
How many pedals are there?
Is it like an organ?
I don't know.
What?
I haven't seen it.
Yeah, because when they're playing,
they're striking-
These were remote, in some senses,
I think, yeah, they're,
like, on a live session
with each other that I could tune into
while I was doing my job.
But I wasn't there when they're
actually doing it, right?
Did you ever meet Alex in person at all?
By the time this podcast
is being recorded I will,
because-
No, we are recording it.
Podcast is live because I wanted to go out
with Derek and Alex
because they were the two,
like, you know, they're also-
So, you have plans to meet him,
but you still have not met him?
I wanna do a celebration,
have dinner with them.
So yes, we will have done that.
But anyway, Alex is, again,
he's not a country guy.
He just has great instincts.
And I think it ended up bringing
this awesome vibe to a lot of the,
so the way that I would describe it
is if you are impressed by guitar
that you hear on the album,
it's him, not me, right?
You know, I'm proficient,
especially as a songwriter
when it comes to,
I can do what I need to do
on a guitar to write a song
and to kinda keep rhythm
and do a picking pattern
and that kinda thing.
But, like, if you're impressed by it,
chances are it was him doing it.
All right, who else you got?
Gunnar Olsen did all the
percussion and all the drums.
That's a good name for
someone to do somethin'.
And this is just a dude
who's a session drummer in New York,
who has worked with a bunch of big stars.
He did all the percussion on Springsteen's
"Western Stars" album.
He's worked with Miley
Cyrus and, you know,
a bunch of people who are more talented
and more prolific than me.
But, again, Derek knows him
and he knew he could do this
kind of, like, Americana style
and he nailed it.
So, thanks to Gunnar.
I'll talk about more musicians
once we get into the individual tracks.
But, again, I wanna think Anna Weber,
who took all the pictures
for the whole thing.
So, any pictures where I look
like I might be a legitimate artist-
Or feeling shame.
Yes.
While the picture's being taken.
That was Anna Weber. Thanks to Anna Weber.
The album art for the album,
you know, the me in
the Water on the front,
that was illustrator Greg
Newbold who painted that,
digitally painted that.
And I don't think he's
done much album art.
He's just like a legit,
like, artist/painter
who does, like, gallery
work and stuff and-
That's cool.
You know, Cara helped me find him online
and he did an incredible job.
Kendrick Kidd, who we used to work with
a long time ago, do a lot of-
Back in the day.
design.
He designed the James and the Shame logo.
And then Cara, Cara Powers, our assistant-
Kendrick designed the first
Good Mythical Morning logo.
The flame.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, see? Yeah.
And the Rhett & Link logo that has us,
we look like one chess
piece, like two faces facing-
Yeah, the two heads, the
one head and two faces.
Yeah, he also did that.
Yeah.
And then Cara Powers, our assistant,
who spent a lot of her time
working on this with me
in finding these talented people.
So, it was just so cool because I just,
you know, we haven't done
anything like this in a while
because we have this incredible
team here at Mythical
that we have an idea, and the
team implements that idea,
but this was kinda more the
old school way we used to work,
which is like, "Hey, we need somebody.
Let's find somebody online
that we like their work
and we can just collaborate with them."
It was really cool
just when you bring
somebody into a process
and they make something into what it is.
Well, without further ado,
we can start listening to the song.
But you know what, I might
as well just talk quickly
so we don't break up the album.
Let's talk about We're Still Good.
We're Still Good.
This is the party game from Mythical.
For all of your friends to get together.
You play a card.
It has a blank, it's a crazy scenario
that then everybody submits
what they think should fill in the blank,
person chooses what makes
that scenario horrible,
and then everybody needs to
write a positive spin saying
"We're still good" to turn
it into something positive.
So it's like-
It's a very fulfilling game.
It's good for your soul.
It'll make you laugh.
It'll also help you reframe things,
if you're into that therapy.
Which is important. I
think it's important.
Reframing. Language is important.
Stoic philosophy.
Yeah, we heard from a therapist
that said they were
using it in that context.
We're Still Good.
Available at amazon.com.
It took me a while to figure out
what the album order is going to be.
And actually this process right now
is committing me to the album order.
Oh, okay.
Well, okay.
Yeah, I gave some input into this,
so I'm curious how it's gonna shake out.
I uploaded them.
I uploaded the songs yesterday.
I could technically-
I have not listened to them
in album order before now.
"Believe Me", the first
single, has been out.
We've already listened to it once,
but we gotta listen to it again.
All right, here we go.
♪ I think you want an answer ♪
♪ I'm not prepared to give ♪
♪ 'Cause the one I gave you said that ♪
♪ That ain't it ♪
♪ Must be something that I want ♪
♪ Fame and fortune or at
least a little jaunt ♪
♪ It may seem too cut and dried ♪
♪ But I just found some things ♪
♪ I could not brush aside ♪
♪ Now if you'll oblige ♪
♪ I don't think it's true ♪
♪ I'm not asking you to agree ♪
♪ I'm just asking you to believe me ♪
♪ You say my heart was never true ♪
♪ That might say more about you ♪
Love it.
First single.
You know, we've already
talked about this one
when the single came out,
so I don't wanna retread
any of that ground.
But we have the benefit of, like,
you've heard the most fan
feedback from this song
because it's been out
the longest, you know.
So, one I'm kinda curious about,
like, what's that experience been like?
Are people getting it?
Are people, you know, what is it,
what kinda conversation is it leading to?
Because most of the
people who are listening,
at this point, listening to my music
are people who are already fans of us.
We're getting, like, the
reaction to this type of music
from people who are just fans of us,
which doesn't mean they're
fans of country music.
Now, we have a subset of Mythical Beasts
who are fans of country
music, but the most common,
and, first of all, the
response has been so positive
from a musical standpoint.
I'll talk about, you know,
thematically that response.
But surprise.
You know, people are like,
"Oh," you know, "I didn't,"
people do this kinda
thing all the time, right,
and it's a trope.
It's a trope for if you're
doing this one thing in
entertainment, you're like,
you always just think, "I
can also do music," you know.
I think the thing that
is a reminder to people-
I think podcast is the new
version of that would be, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Is that we started our
career as musicians.
So, this is going back
to the basics for me
in a lot of ways.
The first thing we ever did
professionally as entertainers,
it was music based, you know.
But people are still
surprised because, you know,
they come on board at certain points and-
Yeah, right.
It's always like, "What? You do this?"
I mean, we've had fans
of our music for years
who are like, "Yeah, what
about a serious album?"
So, it kinda scratches that itch for them.
But there's a lot of people who,
yeah, it's like they never
knew what sound it would be,
that it would be so country.
The most common response is,
"I'm not a fan of country music,"
or, "I hate country
music, but I love this."
And it's interesting.
I'm seeing the same exact thing
'cause, you know, when
we're recording this
I just put "Where We're
Going", the second single out,
the same exact reaction in terms of,
"I don't like country,
but I like this song too."
And a lot of people are now saying,
"Hey, it's not that you
don't like country music,
it's that you've been listening
to the wrong country music.
You've been listening
to radio country music.
You've been listening to
what's popular on the radio,"
nobody listens to the radio anymore,
but you know what I'm saying,
it's a certain type of sound.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's all these songs about
trucks and, you know,
God and country or whatever.
And it's, like, this is not that.
And I think people, it's like,
"Oh, you actually do like
broadly country folk, Americana,"
however, there's multiple
ways to describe this.
Yeah, you're turning people onto it.
Well, I wanted to shout-out
a couple of moments.
Well, the one lyric
early on, when you say,
"'Cause the one I gave you
said that that ain't it,"
I like that lyric because
you've got the you,
which is the end of one sentence,
the beginning in the next sentence, right?
Am I hearing that right?
No-
"'Cause the one I gave you
said that that ain't it".
No, "'Cause the one I gave,
you said that ain't it".
Oh. Oh.
But you can hear it that way.
I always hear it more colloquially.
It also makes sense that way.
I gave it to you, you said that ain't it.
Well, I mean, that's
what I'm saying, yeah.
It is what you're saying.
But you actually didn't
do what I thought you did.
No, I just said 'cause the one I gave,
you said that ain't it.
Yeah, that makes more sense.
But it's also the one I gave
you, you said that ain't it.
That needs to be how you,
you need to take credit for that.
Okay.
Okay, I did it on purpose.
What about, you know, in the chorus
you say "My heart was never true,
that may say more about you",
Is that the type of thing
that it speaks for itself or?
I'm curious, what does
this say about people?
Well, I don't know.
That's for them to figure out.
Okay, yeah. I respect that.
But I think that, you know,
the reason that this is the first song
is because it's, this is
what I explained before,
musically, I think it kinda sets a tone.
But, thematically, like the album order,
more than the musical progression,
I leaned into the thematic
progression of like,
"If you were to sit down with me
and I were to begin talking to
you about my deconstruction,"
which is not even really
something that I want to do
unless somebody starts asking me about it,
especially now, I don't, you know,
I'm not interested in
changing people's minds
as much as I may have
been at an earlier point,
but like, "What is the process
that I would lead you through
as I was kind of trying
to explain myself," right?
This is obviously a super
self-indulgent project
on multiple levels.
But also just the fact that I
think I got something to say
and that you should listen to it, right?
And there is self-indulgent.
But if I am talking to you
regardless of where you're at
on the spectrum of
spiritual deconstruction,
Christianity, whatever, this
kinda sets the tone of saying,
"The point of this is not for you to agree
with what I'm saying.
The point is just listen."
If somebody is gonna tell you
about their spiritual experience,
take their word that
they're the closest to it
as they can possibly be
and that they're being honest with you
in what they're saying.
And so if your perspective at
the end of the day is that,
"Oh, you never were a Christian,"
and you may be committed to that
because of some theological
perspective that you have,
again, that says more about you.
In that instance, if you think
that I wasn't a Christian,
actually there's nothing about me
that demonstrates that
I wasn't a Christian;
it's you and your commitment
to a specific ideology
that makes you see me in a certain way.
So, when you say my heart was never true,
that says a lot more about you
than it does about me in my experience.
Yeah, and who wants to talk to somebody
who's not gonna listen to,
who's not going to believe
what they're saying,
but instead just try to put 'em in a box
and, like, mind their true motives.
Like, assuming that you're lying to me,
my goal in this conversation
is to find the real truth.
That's what I'm gonna
do here today, Rhett.
Just kidding.
No, like, I know how that feels.
Yeah, I mean, we felt a lot of that.
And I think it's the
perfect start to the album.
So, before I move to the next song,
I wanna thank Casey Frank.
You're gonna thank people every time, huh?
Well, as we get new
instrument, instrumentalist.
All right, fine.
Casey Frank played that organ.
That's a real organ.
Like, we had a fake
organ in there originally
and I was like, man, you know
me, I'm not a details guy.
But Derek's like, "You know,
we gotta get a real organ,"
and I'm glad he did.
There's no fake instruments
in any of this stuff.
That was recorded by Talley
Sherwood at Tritone Recording.
And then the music video,
the lyric video/music video,
again, that was done by Jax Anderson,
she makes incredible music on her own
and does incredible directing.
And so shout-out to Jax Anderson.
Buddy System Season One theme song.
Yes.
That's right.
Yeah.
Okay, for the second song,
this may be a surprise to you,
this is actually responding to some input
that I got from you,
but also as I really
started thinking about what,
there was a point at which
I thought I was gonna do
the first three singles
were gonna be the first
three songs on the album.
But then as I started thinking,
there's multiple things going into this.
'Cause you're like, "Who am
I thinking about when I,"
I'm thinking about the listener,
I'm thinking about somebody who's like,
"I like country music.
Who's this new kid on the block,"
or, "I'm a fan of Rhett and Link,
and I don't even like country music,
but what's Rhett got to say here?"
I couldn't decide who I
was making that thing for,
so I just stuck with themes
and it just ended up being that
we're still a very in,
like, classic country
on the second song.
I went with "Flash of
Rationality" as a second song.
And we could talk about
it after we listen to it.
All right I'm ready.
♪ Sometimes I have a
flash of rationality ♪
♪ But most times I do
just what I'm goin' do ♪
♪ It's easy for me to
see what I already see ♪
♪ Ain't got time for inconvenient truths ♪
♪ I'm just a man, I ain't no machine ♪
♪ I do the math the way it suits me ♪
♪ Don't get me wrong,
you're making some sins ♪
♪ But I think I'll go
before I am condemned ♪
♪ Sometimes I start ♪
I love that one.
I mean, it goes even more country, like-
It's probably the most country.
Right down the middle.
But, I mean, it's got this
very vintage country vibe.
You know, it's got a
Charley Crockett type retro-
Well, when you hear
something in your mind,
it's one of those things
where, like, what I was,
that's my homage to Merle, you know.
That's why there's a trumpet in there.
That's my homage to my favorite era,
and your favorite era, of
Merle, late '70s, early '80s
when he was, like, bringing in jazz.
And, of course, once I put my spin on it,
it ends up in a different place
so you might have to be told
that that's the reference.
But the reason I put that song there
is, again, I wanna be like,
"Hey, this is a country album."
It's the shortest song on the album,
it's under three minutes,
it's the only one that's
under three minutes,
and so I kinda wanna be like,
"All right, from streaming perspectives,
like, I'm in at this album,
I get to that second song."
But from a thematic
standpoint, it's kinda saying,
"Listen, first song I told you,
you don't have to agree with me.
And in the second song, I'm telling you,
I also don't know what I'm talking about."
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, it's self-deprecating.
I'm, like, I don't think I got
something incredible to say.
I don't think I've got some
incredible insights into this.
I think that I'm smarter
than I actually am.
I buy a lot of books, I
don't finish reading them.
Sometimes I think
straight about this stuff,
a lot of times I don't.
I'm just being honest with you.
This isn't some treatise that
you're supposed to, like,
be aligned with what's going on here.
I'm just guessing it the same
way that you are, you know,
it's kind of the thematic message
and that's what I wanted
it to be at this point.
And that trumpet.
Yeah, I mean, it is a surprise
first time you hear it.
Like, I mean, I heard it a
lot later in the album before.
It was, like, maybe four
from the end when I heard it,
and I was like, "Oh,
you gotta move this up."
Especially when that
trumpet came in, it's like,
"Oh, you give people this surprise."
Well, I got a funny
story about the trumpet.
So, I knew from the beginning
that I wanted a trumpet.
And the way that I indicated
that I want a trumpet
is when I sent Derek the demo,
which is just me playing
a guitar and singing,
it got to that part of the song
and I just did a mouth trumpet.
Yeah, as you would, I guess.
And nothing like a good mouth trumpet.
And he told me, he was like,
"Hey, trumpet players, it's tough."
He's like, "We can get guitarists all day,
but trumpet, brass players,
they're harder to get,
they're more expensive," whatever.
And I was like, "Really?"
Okay, and you knew you
wanted trumpet, not sax,
because I mean, Merle he
traveled with a sax player,
not a trumpet player.
But he had some trumpet solos.
And more like the Spanish, you know,
influence songs actually.
I was hearing trumpet more
than I was hearings sax,
like, you know, like, muffled-like,
but the thing on the end-
Yeah, definitely makes sense.
So then we actually talked
to, I talked to Ward,
our friend Ward Roberts.
You know, he's actually pretty
connected in the music world
and his dad's like a jazz player.
So I was like-
Trombone.
"We can't find," and
he goes like, "I know,"
and he sends me, like, a list.
And Chris Bautista was the
first person that we contacted
and he was down to do the project.
And he was like, "What
do you want me to play?"
And I said, "Well, I've
already done a mouth trumpet
of the melody."
And I was like, "You can play that,
and then play some other stuff."
And then at the end of the day,
we just all liked just him
doing exactly what I did
with the mouth trumpet.
So, you got him to play a mouth trumpet.
That sounded like a real trumpet to me.
I'm gonna play you the demo.
This is the only demo I'm gonna play
because I want you to hear the final songs
and I don't wanna be here forever.
But I thought this was funny enough.
You don't wanna be here forever?
Where you gotta be?
To play you the demo.
The demo trumpet, all right.
I'll play a little bit of
the song to see just how,
what I do ain't as good
as what we do collectively
once it gets in the hands of a producer.
♪ I know just enough about enough stuff ♪
♪ To not when you bring somethin' up ♪
♪ Talking out of my ass is my MO ♪
♪ I'm trying to learn
to say I don't know ♪
Yeah, he did better than you, man.
His mouth trumpet's a lot better.
He made that sound awesome.
And then he added the like .
Yeah, yeah, a little ending.
Yeah, so that's "Flash of Rationality".
I mean, the melody was
intact, though, you know.
He played the same thing.
I'm talking about your singing melody.
Oh yeah, that one,
and this was the second to
last song written, by the way,
the "Flash of Rationality".
'Cause I wanted that theme of like,
I started realizing that,
as you get into the album,
I'm flirting with, the
whole thing is flirting
with self-importance and
self, you know, indulgence.
But I just wanted to remind you that,
hey, I don't think I'm some smart-ass,
I am a smart-ass, I'm more of
a smart-ass than a smart guy.
So, just wanted to remind you.
Yeah, I appreciate you
moving it to a disclaimer
placement in your album
instead of burying it.
Yeah, right.
And also the fact that
it's one of my favorite
songs on the album.
Yeah, it's a good vibe.
You can walk down the street to it.
You can walk back the other
way down the street to it.
Third song is the third single
that just came out a week
before the album dropped
"Give a Damn".
Okay, yes.
So, I put this one
early in the mix as well
and it's pretty big departure.
Let's listen.
♪ Ain't it funny how some guys who lived ♪
♪ Well before your time ♪
♪ Make you think what you think ♪
♪ God thinks about wine ♪
♪ The kind of thing will draw you in ♪
♪ And you are like me ♪
♪ Why live for the here and now ♪
♪ When you've got eternity ♪
♪ They say your life unexamined ♪
♪ Is a life that's not worth living ♪
♪ But I'm pretty sure I grayed my beard ♪
♪ With all these fucks I've given ♪
♪ I can't help but give a damn ♪
♪ But damn, sometime I wish I didn't ♪
♪ First time I heard of the great beyond ♪
♪ I was surely smitten ♪
♪ I could be one of the chosen few ♪
♪ Be on the front lines ♪
♪ I've got something in my pocket ♪
♪ That'll give sight to the blind ♪
Woo!
Yeah, that's a good one, man.
Yeah, I had already heard
"Believe Me" a lot early.
I heard the first two singles-
Really early-
So by the time I listened to the album
this is the one that was, like, let's see,
we were on a plane.
We were getting on a plane.
You were listening to the album
and we were in the airport.
Yeah, it was one of those things
where I had to leave my phone off
airport mode, airplane mode,
even though we were taking off
'cause I was trying to get
the last song finished.
And I'm like, "Man, what's
gonna happen," all right?
Somebody gonna come up to me
and, like, kick me off this plane?
Yeah, they threw you right out the door.
You know, I had to get started to finish.
But then my first, you
know, I leaned over to you.
You happened to be there.
It was such a coincidence.
And I was like, "That
was the 'Give a Damn'."
I was like, "Give a Damn".
Whoa, that's the one right there.
I mean, listening to it again here,
I'll tell you what's my favorite,
but that was, like, the first
one I wanted to talk about.
So, let's talk about it.
I mean, the guitar hook right off the bat.
Did you do mouth guitar for that?
Nope.
My guess is that was part of the solo
and then you retroactively moved
the second half of the solo
to be the intro, but am I
getting too in the weeds here?
Well, actually I don't know exactly,
I don't know what that
process was exactly.
Because, you know, obviously
this is the one demo
that when I sent it over I added,
you know, I record and logic,
and then Derek is the pro-tools guys,
but I did a beat, I was
like, "This is a rock song."
This is like, in my mind, like
an Avett Brothers rock song
'cause you've got that kind of like,
no, but they don't do lead
guitar in the same way,
but that's what I was hearing.
Usually.
And so-
It's got that banjo in it, okay.
So, I dropped a beat in there really
so I could play with the groove
and it gives me the energy
that I need to sing in the demo.
It's the only song that I did that on.
And I was just like, "Listen, I want,"
there's a couple songs where I was like,
"I want Alex to let loose on this
because we need something
powerful and hooky on this."
And, you know, typically
Derek was semi something
and give me a couple options
to this that he sent over,
and I was like, "That's it.
That's that hook that it needed."
Oh yeah.
I mean, it's interesting
that you said it was rock
because it did not turn out that way.
I mean, it's quite a jaunt to use the word
that you used in the first song, but-
Folk rock.
Yeah, okay.
The Avett Brothers, if
you, like, go to the Wiki,
it doesn't say they're a country band,
it doesn't say they're a bluegrass band,
it says they're a folk
rock band, you know.
And I think this is a folk rock song.
Like, the chicken pecking of that intro,
actually that was very Merle to me.
But I'm talking more '60s, which I liked.
I don't know if you even felt
like that was a connection.
But it was like "Workin' Man Blues".
I hear that.
I also hear a hint of Lynyrd Skynyrd.
Yeah, the slide lead.
Slide guitar.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I mean, you could hear
Jackson Browne in that too.
I'm just saying it's interesting-
I'll take a little Skynyrd.
I mean, when you add that banjo
and then you add a bunch of fucks given,
This is the explicit lyrics song.
Is it gonna have an E on-
Yeah.
Oh yeah, you playing the
Mumford and Sons card.
When I uploaded the song-
There's an explicit track on this.
Is this Mumford and Sons album?
It doesn't mean as much as it used to.
No, it doesn't.
And also I've noticed
that, like, certain artists
in this genre who, like,
if Father John Misty
says the F word in a song,
he doesn't put explicit lyrics on it.
Interesting.
It was like, "Well, I'm gonna do it.
Okay, I'm gonna do it."
One last thing about the
production, the gang vocals.
Like, yeah, it just felt like it was,
it was such a relief when that showed up.
I just felt like-
A relief?
Yeah, 'cause I was like,
"Oh, that's where this
needed to go," you know.
In a good way.
Yeah, and that's just me and Derek
standing in his studio
12 feet from the mic.
Just me and you have done
gang vocals a hundred times,
where you're trying to do
multiple voices and stuff.
Did you do any Muppet voices?
I didn't hear any Muppet voices.
I said I'm not gonna do the high voice
because that makes it
sound like the Muppets.
I was like that's one
thing that I've learned
from me and Link-
Yeah, it was more, you
know, friends in low places-
People at a bar.
Kind of a vibe.
Kinda thing, yeah.
Yeah, bar sing-along.
Yeah, definitely that
sealed the deal for me,
between the guitar at the opening
and then the gang vocals at the end.
But this song, I mean, is
about evangelism, right?
Yeah.
But you can be an evangelist of anything.
It's just that we're
very steeped in a church
that had the label because it was such,
so key to our-
And as I talked about a lot of times,
my personality is evangelistic.
I like to persuade people,
and I don't necessarily
like that about myself,
and this is a song about, man,
I can't help but give a damn
but sometimes I wish I didn't, you know.
It doesn't make your life easier
when you like to change people's minds.
When you first heard
about the great beyond-
And also yeah-
You were smitten.
I think there's something about people
who feel like there's
gotta be some purpose.
They're naturally drawn to religion.
And really when they're
involved in a religion,
they really go for it.
Like, I became a missionary
because I thought
that this is the most
important thing in the world.
Like, this is so much more important
than every other earthly thing
that, "How do I go all in?"
Well, you do it full-time.
And so that's why I became a missionary.
And so-
Okay, go ahead.
I have another question.
And then so what?
Yeah, but then when you switch teams,
you become an evangelist for that team.
Well, the second time you say it
it's not the great beyond, it's-
The first time I saw someone's eyes-
Someone's eyes light up.
So, is that, like, catching
the bug of converting somebody?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, if I can sit down and talk to you,
like if you're a conservative Christian
and I can have a conversation with you
and make you question
some fundamental things
and it seems like a light bulb goes off,
there's something, you know,
incredibly rewarding about that.
It's the same part of
your brain that lights up
when you're evangelizing
someone and they come to Christ.
You think that you're doing it,
and you might be doing it out of love
and belief that this
person's soul is being saved,
but it's incredibly, personally rewarding.
If you were to scan somebody's
brain who was having,
was doing evangelism and
someone was converting,
the serotonin, you know, would be,
whatever the brain chemical is,
you would be getting that reward,
you would be getting
the reward that you get
from, you know, winning at a game.
Dopamine, you know.
It's a dopamine rush.
Okay.
And that is in my personality-
Hit the dopamine molecule.
So, when I go to the other team, I,
and, again, the music
video for this is out,
the music video for this
is currently not been finished being made.
It's an animated music video from-
You're telling the future.
From Micah Buzan, who is
this incredible animator
who made that music video.
You know, the song is
a departure musically
and so the visual is
very much a departure.
And it's kinda symbolizing
this in sort of,
as an analogy in a
different world kinda thing.
But the whole point just being that,
again, the reason this is the
third song is multipurpose.
Number one, it's like,
hey, this is another place
that we're going on this album.
It's not just country.
We're getting into some different stuff
that is broadly country, but
this Americana, folk rock,
whatever you wanna call it.
But thematically, it's like,
hey, I just told you that I'm
not, don't take me seriously
'cause I'm not taking myself as seriously
as I might seem sometimes,
but also, hey, I don't even like the fact
that I wanna change your mind.
I don't even like that about myself.
It's making me age more quickly.
But, you know, I'm
processing it through music.
The gray in your beard
started under the ears almost.
And in the middle and.
And now in the middle.
Yeah, and that's, you know,
there's multiple reasons for that.
So this section of the album, three songs,
where now that I've sort of thematically
sort of tried to position
myself a little bit as like,
this is how I want you to kinda take
what's about to come out,
before I start preaching at you
because I am gonna preach at you
before the end of the album,
now I'm directing my process
towards people I love,
starting with my parents,
then going to my wife,
and then going to my kids.
Because spiritual deconstruction,
which is an overused term,
but you know what I'm talking about,
basically moving away
from traditional beliefs
or reorganizing the way
you think about this,
reorienting yourself, and
in my case deconconverting,
is very complicated for
the people that you love,
especially if they are
still in that faith, right?
And so this is a song that was written
as I process the way that
I feel towards my parents
and my parents feel towards me.
It's called "Sorry".
♪ I never set out to do ♪
♪ Something to disappoint you ♪
♪ Approval was sorta my thing ♪
♪ Took your book and made it mine ♪
♪ Never colored outside the lines ♪
♪ And made my own peace with the king ♪
♪ But then the integrity ♪
♪ You'd poured deep inside of me ♪
♪ Started to burn a hole in my heart ♪
♪ I grabbed on that scarlet thread ♪
♪ And pulled 'til there was nothing left ♪
♪ And then my whole world fell apart ♪
♪ You did nothing wrong ♪
♪ And I did nothing wrong ♪
♪ So why do I feel like I need ♪
♪ To say sorry in a song ♪
♪ I know you ♪
What's the answer?
Why do you feel like you
need to say sorry in a song?
I don't know.
I don't have the answer.
I think this is something that
anybody in this similar situation,
like you love and respect your parents,
you were a good kid,
you know that this is a
disappointment to them,
in spite of how well your life has gone
or how well things are with your family
and your career and all this stuff,
if you disagree on this fundamental thing,
it's a disappointment.
You know, I think about my kids
and I try to explain this to Locke
to kinda get him to
understand the dynamic here.
Even though my parents
really, really love me,
because I have deconverted
and publicly deconverted,
it's kind of a double whammy.
Not only am I no longer a Christian,
but I'm this public
figure who talks about it.
You know the world that we come from
and you know how those
kids are seen, right?
You know how people see
me, and that impacts them.
And the thing that I'm trying
to say in this song as well
is that like, well, to
finish that thought,
I was like, Locke, if, you know,
we've kinda raised you according
to a certain worldview,
it's a much more permeable worldview
than the one that I was given.
I'm not telling you exactly what to think,
but there are certain values
and there are certain things
that we hold, you know,
leading with love and
being kinda the main value.
And I was like, if you
were to, like, go off
and become some guy who
is, like, contrary to this,
you know, in some way,
there's multiple ways
that you could do that,
like, that would be difficult for me.
But, multiply that times 10
when I would become worried
about your eternal destiny,
that's what my parents live with,
and that's what the parents of many people
who've deconstructed and
deconverted live with.
Thankfully, we still
have a great relationship
and we love each other.
And love trumps everything else, right?
The love is stronger than the faith,
which that's what Jesus
himself said, right?
Faith, hope, and love, the
greatest of these is love.
If you lose the love,
you've lost the plot.
But I feel bad.
Like, the idea of my mom crying about me
in my eternal destiny, that hurts.
Yeah, it hurts you because it hurts her.
You know, you broke their hearts.
And you didn't do anything wrong,
but you certainly don't, you know,
the sign-up sheet to
break your parents' hearts
is not something that people
are lining up for, you know,
especially with the type of
relationship that you have,
you not only had, but have with them.
Yeah, so you're able to
say, "You did nothing wrong-
And what I mean by that-
But it's hard for you to say, you know,
they've done nothing wrong either.
The reason I say they've done
nothing wrong is because,
again, I know what it's like
to be an evangelical Christian.
And when your kids
depart, not only do you,
like, it's built into that community
that you become responsible for it.
The Bible basically implies
that in a couple of places
that, like, your kids' outcome,
I mean, it's a gray area for sure,
there's ways to interpret
and get around it.
But, like, regardless
of what the Bible says,
the evangelical community blames parents
for what their kids end up doing.
And so that's the feeling.
It's like, "You didn't do anything wrong,"
like, when I talk about the fact that,
that's why I did that Instagram post like,
"You guys taught me the gospel.
I understand what the gospel means.
I understand grace by faith.
I'm not legalistic.
You guys were never legalistic,"
I didn't miss the boat in that way.
I mean, yeah, it kinda-
You didn't do anything wrong.
Parents get bad rap across
the board, you know.
It's like, "Why is so and
so guilty of this crime
or now in prison?"
It's like, "Well, how did their
parents fail 'em," you know.
And I'll go a step further and say
not only did they not do anything wrong,
they did a lot of things right.
And this is a very difficult thing
that I'm saying in this song that I can't,
you know, I haven't-
The integrity that they gave you
burned a hole in your heart.
My parents' concern with truth,
especially my dad because
he thinks a lot like me.
My dad became a Christian
in his early 30s,
so a later life conversion, right?
So, it was a very strong conversion
that was immediately, like, impacted him
in so many different ways.
And my mom as well.
They both became Christians
at the same time.
In his concern, his
lifelong concern with truth
and putting truth above everything else,
my personality's exactly the same way.
And the thing that I want
to be able to say is that,
"Hey, the same thing that got you
to suddenly wake up in your early 30s
and realize that life has got to be
about more than just
going through the motions,
like there's gotta be more to this life,
and that led you to making a
profession of faith in Christ,"
that was truly life-changing, I believe.
That same instinct is what brought me
to the conclusions that I came to.
So, it's actually what
you did right, ironically,
to make me really concerned
about truth and like,
"Hey, if this is the most important thing,
I wanna understand, is it really true?"
And I came to my conclusion
that I am at right now,
I always leave room, I say right now
because I leave a lot of things open,
is that it's not true, fundamentally.
It's not true.
Christianity is not true.
If I thought that it was true,
I would still be a part of it.
I don't think that it's true.
I think that there's a
lot of things about it
that you can't know.
But what I'm saying is like,
even though I made a
lot of these decisions
because of the good things
that you passed along,
I know it still deeply disappoints you
and I'm sorry about that.
So, the part of like,
why do I feel like I
need to say I'm sorry,
like, yeah, I think that,
I know that resonates,
that totally makes sense.
But let's talk about the in a song part.
Why do I feel like I need
to say I'm sorry in a song?
You know, are there certain things
that you're saying in this song
that you couldn't say to their face?
I think that applies to this,
this song and many other ones.
I don't talk this way to
people directly, you know,
even in the next couple
songs we'll listen to.
It's the same thing.
It's like, I can say it
a lot better in a song
than I can just sitting
down and saying it to you.
Specifically with my parents,
it's complicated by the
fact that it's so emotional
and I can't have a real
conversation about this, you know,
without, especially my mom.
Like, she's heartbroken, right?
So, we just don't talk
about this stuff directly.
We talk about the things that, you know,
moms and sons talk about, about life
and what are the kids
doing and that kinda thing.
And maybe we will get
where we can talk more
directly about this stuff,
but it's too hurtful.
Yeah.
I mean, you saying the song that, like,
we're probably not gonna change
each other's minds, right?
Yeah.
So then you're left
with just kind of, it
becomes this emotional thing
that, you know, it is
still may be really raw.
Yeah, yeah.
So, did you feel afraid to even,
to put the song out there?
Are there hopes attached to it
in terms of how you can process
it in that relationship?
Or is that none of the
listener's business?
Yeah, I would say that.
I don't know. I don't know, you know.
I think a lot of these songs
are just as much for, you know,
the reason I didn't just write this song
and sent it to my parents
and I made it a public thing
is because I think this
will resonate, you know.
This is happening.
This is a worldwide cultural movement
of people moving out of
these types of belief systems
that their parents hold very
sacred and it's difficult.
And there's no solution
in this, other than like,
"Hey, I'm just identifying
with the emotion
that this stirs in people."
I think it's absolutely beautiful song
in the way that it resonates
even beyond the context of, like,
changing your religious beliefs, you know.
And I think we've talked
about this before, you know.
Your relationship with your
parent, parents, guardians,
like the people who, you know,
people who are older than you,
as you grow up and you
become an adult yourself,
it's like the nature of
our relationships change.
And sometimes if they don't,
that's weirder than if they do.
But the changes that you go
through in that, you know,
people who love you and were
there for you your whole life
they're making different decisions,
they're landing in a different place,
it's a scary thing to
navigate a relationship
where you have a fundamental
disagreement, you know.
You talk about issues
of identity, you know,
that whether it could still be religious,
it could be, you know, relational, sexual,
whatever the case may be
there's so much that you have to navigate.
I think it's your story
and I think that it will resonate
with other people's stories
in a way that it just kinda,
it sprouts wings.
And that's why I think
this is a beautiful song.
Even if you're just doing
the spiritual exploration,
I think it's a great album.
But this is a standout
because it's so relatable,
sadly, to so many people.
And the irony is, is that, yeah,
you don't have a lot of the baggage,
like, from your parents.
I mean, we all have
baggage, but, like, you-
But it's a lot worse for a lot of people.
You have an active relationship
where, like, you know,
you still wanna spend
time together at holidays
and, like, you care about
each other and it's not,
a wall has not been built up.
You still have a relationship.
Yeah.
You know, listen, I give them
a lot of credit for that.
Because in the system that
they're in, it would not be,
there are certain biblical passages
that you could decide
you were gonna follow
that would mean you would
cut off a relationship,
just to be honest with you.
And they're choosing love.
Yeah, but that doesn't mean
that this wasn't deeply
emotional and difficult
for you and for them.
It's like kind of, you know,
it's under a best case scenario
that it happened and you're
still illustrating the depth
with which, like, there's
parts that you can only express
in certain ways and, like,
you're not able to get into it still.
It's like, I just think about the people
who is, like, everything else,
you know, to add onto it.
So, I think it's a big one, man.
And I wanted to put it
there 'cause, you know,
that's one of my favorite
songs on the album.
I just love the way that one came together
and to kinda start that section.
Of course, the next song
is the second single,
which is me writing a song to my wife.
It's called "Where We're Going".
♪ Picked up on it first thing ♪
♪ You weren't like the ones I'd known ♪
♪ Might have been from the same place ♪
♪ Coming from somewhere all your own ♪
♪ A few hours on a wooden bench ♪
♪ That's all it took to do me in ♪
♪ Knew then I had to make it quick ♪
♪ Before I made us fall into sin ♪
♪ I don't know where we're going ♪
♪ But I know I want you to go with me ♪
♪ Don't care much about the destination ♪
♪ As long as you're there
that's where I wanna be ♪
♪ Talking took a different tone ♪
♪ Started to ♪
You know, it's amazing for
a song that is so sweet
to be about going through so
much difficulty, you know?
I mean, especially when you throw that,
like, classic country,
and I don't mean in terms of time,
I mean just the way that, you know,
the sweetness of a sweet country song,
especially when you go
to that bridge at the end
or whatever you call it, where it's like,
"Now I'm gonna put this
all in perspective."
It's like you followed this template,
which is like, "I'm telling you a story
about a relationship.
You can see the music video in your head."
Typically, the country music
singer would be singing-
And you'd see the couple.
And you see the couple
and it wouldn't be them,
but you did the right thing.
You put yourself and Jessie in the video.
Right, yeah.
Yeah, that was, if you didn't
know, that was Jessie singing.
Yeah, and Ben Eck here,
who's been at Mythical for
almost a decade, you know,
I wanted the whole thing
to be outside of Mythical,
but he was so excited when
he heard about the project.
He was like, "Hey, whatever
I could do to help.
I just wanna be a part of it."
And so we collaborated on the video
and he brought it to life.
But, yeah, getting Jessie to sing,
again, I wrote this song for
her for a Valentine's Day
two years ago or 2021,
and that was back before
this album was a thing,
it was before I even knew that
I was making an album really,
or that it was a country album, right?
So, this song wasn't even
conceptualized as a country song
the first time I wrote it.
You couldn't help yourself, though.
Yeah, I remember.
Yeah, you talked about
singing this song to her
on the podcast.
You alluded to that.
This is the first song
you wrote for the album.
You didn't even know it.
Well, it's not the first song I wrote
'cause I was just writing songs-
What's the first?
As a process.
The first song I wrote is
the last song on the album.
This may be the second song that I wrote.
But, again, there was
a number of songs there
in the middle that were,
I didn't know I was making an album.
I'm just writing music
and, like, recording demos.
I mean, we've talked about it a lot
when we talk about the deconstruction,
in the deconstruction episodes.
But I mean, it brings it into sharp focus
how when your relationship
is built so strongly
on the rock of Christ, right,
that whenever you decide to move
your home base somewhere else,
that is a scary prospect.
And if you both don't
make that move together,
and, again, we didn't make the move
at the same time, you know.
I kinda moved first.
And then Jesse was, you
know, obviously scared,
resistant, crying, that's
what I talk about in the song,
it's just like when I
started having these like,
"This is what I'm thinking.
I really didn't wanna tell you about this
'cause I know how much it'll upset you,"
she would just cry,
you know, it was tough.
It's one of the reasons
it was such a long and lengthy process.
But we eventually got to
where we're not in exactly
the same place spiritually,
it isn't like she wants me to be anywhere
or I want her to be anywhere,
we both are like we're untethered
from orthodoxy, frankly.
But there's so many couples
where that is not the case.
You're in very different
places fundamentally.
And not only is that just
intrinsically difficult,
but you've been told,
if you're from a conservative
evangelical background,
that you cannot be unequally
yoked, that it doesn't work.
And you're also told that
everything that you have in life,
every good instinct that
you have comes from God,
comes from the spirit of God;
and everything bad comes from you.
Again, I'm not speaking
for all your evangelicals,
but this is sort of the
perspective that I had.
All your good instincts are from God,
all your bad instincts are from you.
And what that means is that the moment
that you begin thinking
that this God thing
may not make sense in the same way,
you're just naturally programmed to think
that only bad is now left.
And now what are we gonna
base this marriage on?
Love?
I thought we had to base it on Jesus.
So, this is an example
of some of the things
we were warned about turned out
to be pretty good, you know.
There was a lot of trepidation.
Like, I definitely relate
with me and Christy
in our spiritual journeys.
Like, the trepidation of everything
that you realize you
believed, if it wasn't,
I mean, it was overtly
taught in a lot of ways,
like you're talking about
the unequally yoked thing,
but just how it permeates everything
you don't even know you believe.
You can feel it as fear before
you can state it logically.
And when you're in a
deconstruction process, it's like,
yeah, you're in this state
of fear a lot of times
and you can't articulate it.
But to get through that
with anything that you
get through as a couple
and if you do come out
stronger on the other side,
then you can say, "Oh, wow,
maybe it was worth it," you know, right?
Can't you say that?
I think that when you
strip away the ideology
that was holding you together
and it really becomes about
just love and this commitment,
and, again, I know I give
a lot of these disclaimers,
I'm not saying that
people who are Christians,
who are in a relationship,
that it is all about,
like, it isn't about love,
it's just about their ideology.
The thing I would say, that I
would challenge Christians on
is I actually think that, you know,
a lot of guys in Christian
circles, this is what you hear.
They're like, "Man, if
I wasn't a Christian,
I'd be cheating on my wife."
This is a very common sentiment.
And I'm like, "Dude, that's
some up fucked up shit, man."
Like, "Think about what you just said.
Think about what you just said.
What if the reason you
don't cheat on your wife
is because you love her?"
And here's what I would say,
"I think the reason,"
'cause here's the deal,
infidelity happens a whole lot
with inside and outside of the church.
It seems like that commitment
actually doesn't play much of a role.
And so if you are faithful,
I think it actually means
that you're faithful.
You don't have to constantly give credit
to some external source for
every good thing you do.
Maybe you're faithful
because you have the ability
to be faithful in yourself.
So that is an example of like,
"Oh, this relationship that is,"
and, listen, I'm not perfect,
Jessie's not perfect,
I'm not saying that it's
always gonna be great,
it has continually gotten
better over the years for us
as we've grown together,
but who knows what challenges
we'll meet, you know?
But when the rubber meets the road,
I want our relationship to be based
on mutual love and respect
and a commitment that is independent
of our worldview and ideology, you know.
And I think that that's actually the case
in most relationships,
even the ones where the
ideology is present.
What do you mean by "More
than a savior we needed help"?
'Cause, you know, I think from the,
I don't know, that's
more of a head scratcher.
What I meant by that is
in the evangelical circles
that we ran around in
you get a lot of help from a
spiritual perspective, right?
And even when you go to therapy
or you go to couple's counseling,
it's always run through this
very specific biblical grid.
And it's just like, "If your
relationship with Christ
is intact and flourishing,
then everything else in
your life will be okay,"
is kind of the implication, right?
And I think there are sometimes
when you just need help,
you just actually need
somebody to help you
navigate your relationship,
navigate your own emotional and
mental well-being, you know.
It's funny 'cause I know Christians
who prefer, for their
therapists, to not be a Christian
because they don't want it run
through this biblical grid,
which a lot of times is
more hurtful than helpful.
So, I think that the
point there is that like,
"Hey, it isn't just about getting saved
and having this Savior," this
saving knowledge of Christ,
it's like, no, like couples need help.
They just don't need to be right with God.
They need to figure this .
They need to figure out how
to navigate a relationship.
And I think what we needed,
each individually in our own circumstances
and situations, but also as a couple,
like we needed to work on us
apart from just getting our
worldview straightened out.
Like, that's just not the case.
It's just not true
that if you get the
right belief, you know,
so much of conservative
evangelical Christianity
is about believing the right things.
You go to church on Sunday,
and what do they talk about?
Well, hold on now, we're
not to the preachy-
I can't help myself.
Preachy songs yet.
We're getting there.
And that's our experience, is that,
hey, when we actually started thinking
about our relationship and
thinking about each other
rather than God, things got better.
What's next?
This is the third
in this three-song
section to people I love,
and this is the song
that I wrote for my boys.
Okay, buckle up.
It's called "Creek and Back".
♪ Held you up before God and man ♪
♪ Swore to raise you according to a plan ♪
♪ Then the blueprint ♪
♪ Faded to gray ♪
♪ Still a lot that I want for you ♪
♪ Still a lot that I think is true ♪
♪ It's just now the path ain't ♪
♪ Quite so straight ♪
♪ The secret I probably should not tell ♪
♪ Is that I still feel like a kid myself ♪
♪ Been in over my head
since we brought you home ♪
♪ Biggest thing that I've
learned is what I don't know ♪
♪ But I'm your dad, I know that ♪
♪ And I love you to the creek and back ♪
Another tearjerker, come on now!
So those three together, you
just want everybody to cry.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's got wings, man.
Like I said, in just like
I was talking about before,
you know, any parent's gonna say,
"Oh God, I know exactly
what that feels like,"
to just, should I say that I'm clueless.
I'm just as clueless as you,
but in a different way, you know.
It's extremely powerful
to put that out there.
And I know it's gonna
resonate with people.
And the piano doesn't hurt.
Yeah, I wanted to, you
know, do a piano song.
And it's not me playing the piano.
I know that I learned
how to play the piano for a tour we did,
but that's a real piano
player, Edan Dover.
And, of course, you know,
I wrote it on guitar,
but I was hearing it as piano.
And also it's kinda interesting
because this is the kind
of music that, like,
it's a little more, you
know, it's piano based
so you're kinda getting into, you know,
it's not like a Billy Joel
or a, you know, Elton John song,
but it's the most like that
of anything on the album,
which is kinda like music
that we've connected,
I've connected with the boys over.
But yeah, exactly.
I had written those
two songs to, you know,
a song to my parents, song to my wife,
and I was like, you know,
I think that when you have a
fundamental shift in worldview,
like, again, held you up
before God and man, the first,
that's the dedication,
which incidentally is a piece of video
in the home video footage
in the "Where We're Going" music video-
Oh wow.
Is meet us up there in front
of the church with Locke.
Yeah.
Which is a ceremony, arguably,
just as much, if not,
more about the parents
than it is about the kid.
It's basically saying
you get up in front of
everybody and you say,
"I promise to raise this kid."
You respond to a series of questions.
I'm raising this kid, you
know, according to the gospel,
and you raise them to serve
Jesus and to make a decision.
Yeah.
I mean, in my church, my
kids were actually baptized
and there was an added thing of like-
Well, that didn't save 'em, Link.
You know, that clinging to this promise
that's open to interpretation,
that's like, okay, they are already saved
as long as everybody does their job?
Well, you're kinda claiming
them for Christ, you know.
To me, this song is more powerful
knowing at what stage of
fatherhood you wrote it.
Because I think there's a lot of artists
that will have a child
and then of course they're
gonna start writing songs
about their baby.
There's so many songs,
like an endless playlist of
this artist that you know
had their first baby
and then they had to
write a song about 'em.
Sturgill's whole album,
"A Sailor's Guide to the
Universe" or whatever it is,
it's like it's all based
on him having a kid.
I mean, Childish Gambino.
I mean, but you're looking
at this baby and you're like,
"Ever since the day I brought you home,
I've been scared shitless," you know.
So for you to say that
and, you know, Locke is off at college.
Thank God.
And Shepherd's not as far behind
as it seems like, you know, so it's--
Meaning that it happened.
I don't mean I'm thankful he's gone,
I'm saying that, like, he got there.
So, you see my point, right?
I mean, it's strangely comforting
as a parent to hear this,
knowing that you've got kids
that are on the cusp of adulthood.
Well, I think it goes back
to what we've talked about
as we talk about relating to our kids
that it's much less about
the things that you say
and much more about
the things that you do.
And, you know,
I think modeling
cluelessness to my children,
that's a harsh way to put it,
but modeling humility or whatever
or however you wanna say it like,
"Hey, man, everything that we've done
has been motivated by love.
But it's all guesswork,
and it's the best guess
that we have at the time.
And I know for a fact that
you're going to be processing
the mistakes that I've made forever."
Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I mean, the song is for them first, right?
Hopefully, just hearing
that is helpful to them.
I'm glad-
So you don't end up
with a bunch of resentment, you know.
A parent who can't admit that
they made a bunch of mistakes,
that is much more trauma-inducing
than the mistakes sometimes.
Yeah. I mean, it definitely piles it on.
I'm glad that you didn't
go, like, cute country
and then change "I love you
to the creek and back" too
in the final chorus saying,
"I love you with my creaking back."
Oh, I get it.
Like, I'm so old.
Got it.
"My back sounds like a door."
That would've been a bad-
It's not too late.
Mistake.
It is too late. Where are we going?
Well, "Where We're Going"
is that was the song I wrote to Jessie.
You said "Where We're Going".
From the song title-
What song is next?
Well, before we move on, I wanna say,
so obviously that was Jessie singing along
with that song as well.
So Jessie sings on three songs.
She's the mother of those children.
And so she did an amazing job there.
We wanted to the cello and the violin,
the strings were, like,
a last minute addition
because we had just an
electric bass in there
that Derek had played.
You know, I was like, "I'm
hearing something else,"
and then I heard a song,
I was listening to some song
and there was piano and cello
and I was like, "That's what we need."
So we got Dave Eggar to play cello
and Lisa Fako to play violin.
So thank you for that,
making that song what it is.
Now we're getting back into,
this song is called "Only Thing",
and this is, again, sort
of back to the processing
'cause I'm about to move into a place
where I'm not really
singing two individuals,
but I'm more kinda in my own head
and then finally directing
some things out to the church.
Got a couple of songs
that are directed at the
church towards the end.
But this is back to, like, processing.
Okay.
"Only Thing".
♪ I could argue with the best of them ♪
♪ About where we came from ♪
♪ Convince you over coffee
that Jesus was God's Son ♪
♪ Take that empty feeling
that everybody feels ♪
♪ And use it against you
'till you were on your heels ♪
♪ I was sure as sure can be ♪
♪ I was working for eternity ♪
♪ There was hell to pay ♪
♪ If you saw it another way ♪
♪ Now the only thing I'm certain of ♪
♪ Is that I ain't certain about much ♪
♪ It's easy to be right it's
not so easy to choose love ♪
♪ Sometimes I miss that feeling
of having it figured out ♪
♪ Have to fight that temptation ♪
♪ To know what life's all about ♪
So sometimes it's, I don't
think it's sometimes,
you said it's easy to be right,
you said sometimes it's
not easy to choose love.
So you're talking about this-
It's easy to be right, it's
not so easy to choose love.
So it's like that's the struggle, right?
I mean, you're speaking
from experience here.
Yeah.
This one is just kinda that,
I think that it's very difficult
when you're a Christian.
And I would say, when you adhere
to any particular religious philosophy
and you really adhere to it,
like you're pretty sure that
you're right about, right?
Like, being right about
it is kind of important.
There's a lot at stake.
Specifically, I mean, you know,
believing the creed, believing
the right thing about Jesus
is the ticket to heaven, right?
I mean, ultimately when you break it down,
you gotta think and believe the right,
you gotta believe the right thing.
And your eternal destiny depends on that.
And I think that is difficult
when you're in that situation,
to envision what it would be like
to just not be sure about that.
That's one of the scariest things for me
when I was transitioning
away from Christianity,
which is like, "Whoa,"
like, "This is so crazy,"
to, like, just accept the fact
that you don't have to know
what you think about this stuff,
that you could be
uncertain about this stuff.
And it's really hard.
It's like that's why it says,
in the chorus it's like I'm trying to,
essentially I'm trying to break the habit
of knowing what life's all about, right?
That's a tendency
to, like, you gotta know
what life's all about
and you gotta believe it
strongly and you gotta share it
and you gotta, and it's
difficult to be like,
"No, I can let go of that.
I don't have to know
what the ultimate purpose
of the universe is.
And I believe that anyone who says
that they've got it figured out
almost assuredly is wrong."
Like, the one thing I know
is if you say you know
the secret of the universe is
and what the purpose of all this is,
whatever your particular take on it
you're basically ruling that
out from being the truth
because you've come up, you know,
you and some system of
man has come up with that,
from my perspective.
I think when, from my experience,
when love takes a close second,
like even if it's a razor edge,
like a thin slice just
below truth, it's a problem.
It's a problem when you
start to relate to people,
when you start to try to
empathize with people, you know.
It's hard to love somebody
when there's subservience
to what you believe to
be an absolute truth.
And it always felt weird,
and that's why, for so many years,
I would hide, like, my
beliefs and my affiliation
with the evangelical church,
was because I just couldn't
stand by the implied judgment
that was the headline.
It's like too many people, I fear,
would associate me with
judgment, and not love first.
And I realized that, like,
I related to a lot of people
for so much of my life,
with love being subservient,
and people can feel that .
They know it.
It sticks out like a sore thumb.
Oh yeah, and it's like,
yeah, I mean, that's one of
the big things that, you know,
finally kinda broke me out
of that thinking was like,
just like, it's not something to hide,
it's something to break up away from.
Well, you know, interesting,
I've been thinking about this
exact concept a lot lately.
And the way I've kind of,
the way I understand it right now is
if something about your
particular ideology or philosophy
makes you necessarily think
that someone is fundamentally
different, right?
So, if you're a Christian,
and if you're an evangelical Christian,
and what I mean by that is if you believe
that the only way to be in a
right relationship with God
is through Jesus Christ,
and so if you're not
in a right relationship
with Jesus Christ, you are condemned,
you're not really a child of God, right,
you're gonna spend eternity in hell.
If I believe that about
you, even if I love you,
I think less of you by default.
I think that I'm gonna
spend eternity with God
and I think that you
are not going to spend
eternity with God.
Sure, it may be because of grace
and it may be because of the gospel.
It doesn't make you a bad
person to believe that,
but the relational
dynamic that that creates
is that this person who's
on the receiving end
of that judgment, is what it is,
it is a judgment, it is a determination,
their relationship can
only be so deep with you.
So, if you're a Christian
and you think that I'm going to hell,
again, you may be, that's
your theological opinion,
you can't help yourself believe that,
but I'm saying is that I can only have
so deep of a relationship with you
because there's a fundamental thing
that you believe about
me that separates us
and ultimately results
in me being discarded
and judged in a way that
you're not going to be.
And that's just a difficult dynamic,
that is a result of fundamentalist
belief about things.
But the moment you say,
"Hey, this is my take,"
but I'm not really that certain about it
and I'm not prepared to
say that you're condemned,
the relational possibilities
really open up.
That's a difficult thing to do, though.
That's a very difficult thing to do
if you hold to a particular theology.
Where do we head next?
So, this is the biggest departure,
this is the last song that I wrote.
And I wanted there to be
what I would call a badass country song.
And I'll explain what it means
and why it's in this spot on the album
after we listen to it.
It's called "Kill a Man".
♪ Today I'm gonna kill a man ♪
♪ Gonna squeeze out his
life with my bare hands ♪
♪ He's had it coming for way too long ♪
♪ Only thing he does
right is doing wrong ♪
You can just say it, man.
Just freakin' say it.
Say what?
This was about me.
I'm gonna kill you.
This is me letting you know
that I'm going to kill you.
This is a badass blues guitar.
You got some Kenny Wayne Shepherd in here.
Well, this is-
You got the low notes,
you got the high notes.
Well, here's the thing.
This song was never going
to be a part of the album.
I thought I was done with 10 songs.
Then as we kept producing this thing
and Alex coming through, and I was like,
"This dude's really talented."
Oh yeah, he did awesome.
And I was like, I just feel
like I've gotta write a song
that lets him just like,
"Hey, buddy, I'm taking off the leash.
I'm taking off the leash and
I just want you to be a badass
on the guitar and just
do what you can do."
And so thematically, I
mean, the message is,
and I don't wanna, let me just say,
I'm not gonna say exactly,
there's a principle that was
true in my former philosophy
as a Christian that is true
now as a whatever I am,
hopeful agnostic, that I think
is an important principle
in life that I still abide by.
And this song is a sort of an
exploration of that concept.
Okay.
I'll let you figure out
exactly what that is.
And thanks to Jessie for lending her-
Operatic vocals.
Yeah, you know.
She's done that for us
before back in the day.
You know, Jessie majored in voice,
specifically classical voice.
So, I knew I wanted that
middle section to be like,
kind of a weird departure
and there's like some
backtrack guitars and stuff
or whatever the term is, reverse.
What are the backing vocals
that sound like a chant say?
Are they words?
Which part?
It's like a percussive.
Oh, they just say "yeah, yeah".
They say "yeah, yeah"?
Yeah.
Okay, all right.
Glad we cleared that up.
Yeah, it's a little bit of a,
again, I don't think
there's Jack White song
that sounds exactly like this,
but you could imagine him
having done something like this.
Sure, sure.
You know.
And that's Derek doing that percussion.
He just did it, like, outside
of his studio in Burbank,
like on his driveway with, like, you know.
Sounds like you've killed somebody
and you're draggin' 'em to the-
Well, it's kinda like you've got somebody
and you got 'em in shackles
and you're takin' 'em
to kill 'em, you know.
Oh, that's morbid.
You know, you could take
it however you want to,
but that was what I was thinking.
Now we get, final three songs,
these two that I just put together.
Originally, I wanted them to be spread out
and then I was just like,
I've kinda set the stage to,
these are my two songs
directed at the church.
Okay.
First one is called "In Vain".
♪ There's quite a few things ♪
♪ You don't seem to mind ♪
♪ I'm trying to figure out ♪
♪ Just where you draw the line ♪
♪ 'Cause watching people die ♪
♪ Seems to be fine ♪
♪ But god forbid a nipple
or a Jesus Christ ♪
♪ I sorta understand ♪
♪ It took me quite a bit ♪
♪ Before I'd let an oh my God ♪
♪ Exit from my lips ♪
♪ But maybe that commandment ♪
♪ About using the Lord's name ♪
♪ Is about a lot more than just ♪
♪ What you say ♪
♪ So much done in Jesus' name ♪
♪ Seems to me to be a god damn shame ♪
♪ Are you sure the Savior came ♪
♪ So the righteous would
all vote the same ♪
♪ Tell me who's the one
using His name in vain ♪
See, I feel like there's gonna be
a lot of people, Christians, who are like,
"Hey, I agree with all of that, man.
I agree with all of that."
I think it's difficult,
though, in practice.
I mean, I'm just saying
from personal experience,
to go from yes, it's, you know,
Jesus' teachings and the
biblical teaching can be,
you know, we want to just boil it down
to this actionable stuff
where we can check boxes,
I know for me I wanted to
be able to check boxes,
and say, "I'm well within bounds.
I can feel secure about
my approach to life
and with rules."
And that's not how Jesus talked, right?
And I was taught enough of that to know,
to try to counteract it, but,
I mean, with my tendencies,
I tended to really, when
you boil it down to rules,
and even frivolous ones like,
"Okay, don't say damn, but
definitely don't say goddamn,"
and like, "Don't say,
'oh my God,'" you know,
it's, like, it makes it easier to process,
but none of this stuff
is that easy to process.
It shouldn't be, you know.
But as humans, I think we,
at times you just fall back
on this reductionist approach.
Well, I think it's, you know,
I've always been fascinated
with how offensive
using God's name in vain.
Goddamn, saying goddamn is so,
and this is something I tell people
from other parts of the world
and from other parts of
the United States like,
"If you get upset about something,
you say 'Jesus Christ'",
like that is like ,
like, certain evangelical Christians,
it's like a poison, man.
It is so offensive to them.
And I'm like, so interesting to me
that that is the thing
that is so offensive
but there's all this other stuff
that is actually offensive
that you don't care about.
Hey, wait, yeah, I heard it.
You listed 'em out, nipples.
Well-
Having my nipples.
You know, just it's always
been fascinating to me-
Can I see this music video?
This is the one I wanna see.
It's just one nipple the whole time, so.
Can it sing?
It's a singing nipple, yeah.
Like, where the milk comes out
it can actually starts singing?
That's, yeah, the nipple part.
So, I don't know.
'Cause it's like you're right,
I take that lots of
Christians who would be like,
"I agree with this, but were
you gonna play it for somebody?
'Cause it says goddamn it a
number of times," you know.
And, again, not all
Christians are like this.
A lot of Christians have woken
up to the fact that like,
"Hey, guys, like, cursing,"
and even saying like, "Do you really think
that that's what that
commandment was about,
like, you think the commandment
to not use God's name in vain
was about not using God's
name as a curse word,
like, you really think
that's what that commandment
was ever about?"
It's so interesting that
it's what it became about.
But you're totally right.
Most reasonable Christians
of all stripes will be like,
"Yeah, yeah, completely agree with this,"
like, "That's not what the gospel's about,
it's not about all these other things."
So, yeah.
Yeah, I think ultimately
this is all pretty,
like, soft stuff.
The point of this album
was not to condemn.
It's just-
The Supreme Court case,
I mean, that's something that I think it,
there's a couple of
places where it starts to-
Well, and this song was
written before the Roe v. Wade
that was overturned.
It wasn't in anticipation of
that particular case even.
There's always a Supreme Court case
that Christians think that
God is on the side of an issue
and that that's what Jesus would believe
and that's probably the best one,
is that they just fundamentally believe
Jesus would be pro-life
no questions asked.
And it's just like, "Really, though?"
Like, "You really think that?
Show me the biblical evidence of that."
So anyway, I think this is,
again, it's not like I'm,
like, if you're a Christian
and you're conservative Christian
and you completely,
fundamentally disagree with me
and you've made it to
this point in the album,
it's like, okay, these songs
may be challenging for you.
But, again, this wasn't about,
"Hey, this is a message for
the church first and foremost."
It is, but it's more like
when you are deconstructing
or deconverting, like,
there's a lot of things
that you're thinking and
you're beginning to see things.
You're like, "Man, like, this was the way
that it always was.
This is how we thought.
We were so offended by this thing,
but, you know, all this other
stuff didn't offend us,"
and that's weird and hypocritical.
And you just see it and
you wanna talk about it,
you wanna say it, you wanna
point out the hypocrisy.
But this next song, "Fruit",
is even more specifically
about what I see as the
hypocrisy in the church.
♪ Don't know much about that carpenter ♪
♪ He lived in a very different time ♪
♪ But most everything
that I've heard He said ♪
♪ Makes me think we might
be reading different lines ♪
♪ There was something about
turning the other cheek ♪
♪ I can't quite square
that with your AR-15 ♪
♪ He said let the little
children come to me ♪
♪ But you just watched as they
were torn from their families ♪
♪ I don't feel the love ♪
♪ I don't see the joy ♪
♪ But I'm not sure I got the
patience to argue anymore ♪
♪ I don't mean to be unkind ♪
♪ And I'd like to keep the peace ♪
♪ Just looking for the
self-control to agree to disagree ♪
♪ I remember ♪
This one hits hard, man.
Where's the love?
I don't feel the love.
I mean, if somebody honestly says that,
I mean, you just can't,
it's undeniable, you know.
If somebody doesn't feel
loved, you know, it's,
what can you say to that?
It's one thing for someone to
say, "Yeah, but I love you."
It's like, you know.
I just think even on, like,
an intimate relationship,
have you ever been in a
point when you're like,
someone you loved told you,
"I don't feel the love.
I'm not feeling that from you."
It's like, good luck coming
up with a response, you know.
The damage is already done.
Like, the writing's on the wall
And you can try to explain
yourself at that point.
And I feel like that just
resonates with me so much
because it's, I don't know, I just see it.
It's frustrating.
And I don't wanna paint with
a broad stroke and say like,
"Yeah, this is the problem
with the church overall,"
and like, "Dude, you really
put words in my mouth.
I think that it's," you know,
you give some examples in there
when you talk about AR-15,
when you allude to immigration practices.
Yeah, who's the red-letter
crowd, like define that.
Because I think at that point
you're talking about in
fighting within the church,
that's like you think-
I'm talking about my perspective,
my former self's perspective
on progressive Christians, right?
I used to be like,
so red-letter Christians is a thing that,
it's people who identify
with the words of Jesus.
'Cause there are some
versions of the Bible
where all the words of Jesus are in red
and all the rest of the
words are just black, right?
And so there are people who
say I'm a red-letter Christian
and what that means is that
the thing that I hold the most sacred
and the thing I really take
seriously is the words of Jesus
and then everything else is
sort of open to interpretation
or not as important.
And thinking that way makes you,
you know, Jesus didn't condemn a whole lot
besides hypocrisy, right?
He got condemn by the religious zealots
because He was hanging out with the people
who you shouldn't hang out with, right?
And He didn't come with
a really judgmental tone.
He was like, "I'm about
building relationships.
I'm bringing love into the situation."
And so it's essentially a way of saying,
"Hey, I used to be like
progressive Christians or WACC,"
because they're just not
comfortable with the whole truth.
They're taking the truth
that they're comfortable with
that kinda fits into our cultural context
and is cultural acceptable
and then they're kinda minimizing
or even rejecting the difficult truths
that our culture actually needs to hear
that are in the Bible.
And I was like, "You can't
just say I want this to be true
and this is uncomfortable so
I'm not gonna believe that."
I used to look down on 'em.
And now I'm like, "Those are the people
that I'm rooting for within the church."
It is the ones who were
saying, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I am prioritizing love over judgment.
I'm prioritizing love over faith even,
believing the right thing."
Because it's not so much like, you know,
'cause you might say,
what you said earlier
when you were like, "When
you say I love you, but,"
it's very difficult.
And a Christian might
say, "Yeah, I love you,
but I think that what
you're doing is sinful,
like I can't not say that.
You know, I have to tell you
if I think something
you're doing is wrong."
I don't think we're
talking about situation.
That can get complex, you know.
I think what we're talking about
is the fact that as a whole
the evangelical church,
especially in America, has aligned itself
with, like, the darkest
parts of our nature
as a country, right?
Like, you aligned yourself
with Donald Trump.
I mean, I did a whole podcast about this.
I don't care what the outcome was.
I don't care if the Supreme
Court case went the way
that you wanted it.
You aligned yourself with someone
who is the least Christ-like politician
to ever have been in power in
the United States of America.
Full stop, not an
exaggeration, not hyperbole,
you aligned yourself with the
least Christ-like politician
to ever have been in power in
the history of our country.
I don't feel the love.
The most reliable indicator
for support of Donald
Trump in this country
is if you are a conservative
evangelical Christian.
That is the most reliable indicator.
As long as that's true, you
guys have lost the plot.
You've lost the love, full stop.
That's what this song is about.
Well, you said full stop.
I can't say anything else.
You said full stop twice.
Yeah, full stop. Said it three times.
We didn't even talk about
the fruit illusions.
They can get that themselves.
Fruit of the illusions.
Right, yes, fruit of the spirit.
There's only one more song.
All right. What?
It's called "Old Letters".
And it is the first song that
I wrote of all these songs.
Wrote it in 2019.
♪ I still remember when we used to talk ♪
♪ You never said much but
I knew what You thought ♪
♪ 'Cause You wrote it
down for me long ago ♪
♪ I read Your letters to
keep from feeling alone ♪
♪ There's not just one
thing I could point to ♪
♪ That began to push me away from You ♪
♪ All I can say is that I changed ♪
♪ It was just like You to stay the same ♪
♪ Stay the same ♪
So, the first song you wrote
is the last one on the album.
It makes sense to me that
the first song you wrote
is a letter to God, unless
I'm getting this really wrong.
No, Link, this is to you.
All His letters to you,
this is your letter to Him.
As you're starting the journey
it seems like that's
a good starting place,
like when you told me this
is what you wrote first.
That's why it makes sense to me-
And it wasn't written as
the first of a set of songs.
It was just like, oh, I never write,
I never write about complex emotions.
We write comic songs, you know.
I mean, this might be
the first serious song
I've ever written.
Well, maybe, like, back in
the day when we were writing,
like, Christian music.
Oh yeah, that's true.
Yeah, back in high school.
But yeah, it was very much just,
I'm processing this thing that is
this is kinda how I think about God.
It feels like a breakup.
You think about the
relationship that you had
and you run things back through your mind
and you're like, "What
was I actually thinking?
What was going on?"
But the reason, you know,
this is the last on the album
is, you know, I am
committed to being open,
like I have not closed
my accounts with reality,
I have not closed my accounts with God.
I'm not an atheist.
And the reason that I
say I'm not an atheist
is because I lean into the idea
that there's something else
going on here, you know.
I don't know what that is.
I don't know what the nature of that is.
I don't know what the nature of God is.
I don't know what the
nature of the universe is.
But I don't know what it is,
and so therefore I'm not
ready to conclude what it is.
And it may be that I hadn't
got the first time around
when I was in a relationship with God,
as I would've described
it, I had Him wrong,
I had her wrong, I had it
wrong, I had them wrong,
whatever you want, however you want.
And who knows what the
future holds, right?
If the last 20 years of
my life indicate anything,
it's that the next 20 years could send me
in a wildly different direction
than I would've ever anticipated.
And so the last thing I wanna
do is close myself off to,
if that God out there,
in there, around there
wants to be in relationship
and wants to reveal some
kind of truth to me,
I'm not gonna be the
one to stand in the way
of that God doing that.
And so I leave it open and unresolved.
I enjoyed the production technique
of, like, the pan vocals.
But is there irony in the fact that
your processing of God's letters
is, like, a conversation with yourself?
So, there's a Jason
Isbell song that I love,
"Chaos and Clothes" I
think is the name of it,
and he does this technique of
basically doubling his voice
and the stereo split of the two voices.
And I knew I wanted to do a song like this
and I thought that this song
was a perfect one to do it
because it just represents
the possibility.
To me, it's not some,
it is interesting that
you take it that way,
which I'll take that.
I'm not taking credit for it,
but, like, is this just a
conversation with myself?
This is why this is the
only song on the album
where I did my own
harmony 'cause I was like,
this is so personal, that it's like,
so there's two melodies
and there's two harmonies
and there's two guitars and
it's just, like, represents
the multiple perspectives and how,
where we go from here is
something that is just kinda,
it's open, the possibilities
are open and I don't know,
I'm not trying to go any particular place.
Well, you know, I celebrate the fact
that this thing exists, it's out there,
it's a complete project.
I mean, I know, with everything
that you've been through
and how the pandemic, in a lot of ways,
gave you the space to make this possible,
there's still a lot of
stuff that's going on
and more every day.
It's, like, it's nice
that you followed through
on this vision and this is out there
and, you know, it'll outlive you.
You mean it's still
gonna be on the internet
after I'm dead.
Oh yeah.
That's great.
I mean, as a project,
I think it's important
and I celebrate it.
Well, thanks for that,
and thanks for listening to it with me.
You know, I think that the
most rewarding part so far
has been the people who, and,
again, when I record this-
The horrible cover songs?
There's been a lot of great cover songs.
There's only two tracks out at
the time that I record this,
you know, the first two singles.
But the most rewarding thing,
and again this is what I
said from the beginning,
if one person is like,
"Ah, I relate to this,"
like, you wrote a theme
song for my life situation
or what I've been through
in this relationship,
that's been the most rewarding thing,
is people giving that
feedback and saying that like,
"You put into words what I've
been feeling and thinking
and haven't been able to say," you know.
And, again, I talked about,
part of the inspiration for
this album being David Bazan,
Pedro the Lion, and specifically his album
"Curse the Branches", which
obviously different musically
and different thematically,
but it was like a deconstruction album
from way back in the day,
when I was in the very
beginnings of my deconstruction.
And it was just so, like, I kept,
I listened to that album so many times
'cause I was like, "Man,
people," I just didn't,
there wasn't enough music out there
that resonated with specifically
this very difficult thing
that I was dealing with.
And more people are doing it.
There's more deconstruction.
Again, I hate to use the word.
It's overused, but it's
the best descriptor.
There's more and more music that connects
with everybody who's
experiencing this stuff.
I just wanted to do my
part to get it out there.
So thanks for listening.
Do you happen to have a rec?
It's your week.
I guess if I have to search deeply,
I would say that I recommend
that you listen to my album.
"Human Overboard" is
the name of the album.
James and the Shame is
the name of the artist.
That's me.
And it is available
everywhere you stream music.
And I will ask, you know, it's funny,
I don't know what it'll be like
by the time this comes out,
but I see, like, on Spotify,
like, people also like
and everybody who they also like
is, like, another internet
famous person who does music.
And so I guess it's inevitable
that that's what the case is.
But I would just say, "Hey, listen,
if this album was your
introduction to country
or Americana, hey, there's a lot
of really good stuff out there," you know.
I've put together that
playlist a while back
that was, like, some of my inspirations.
Listen to that music, not
only for your own benefit
because there's a lot of great
country music that's out there,
but also it'll start to show up
that people also like country music.
Not Ninja Sex Party.
Nothing against Ninja Sex
Party, we love those guys,
but I don't think that Ninja Sex Party
is the greatest entry point
into James and the Shame.
No, it's not.
So, do some listening
to train the algorithm,
if you don't mind.
All right, as always, you can
call us, leave us voicemail,
give us your reaction
as we play 'em at the end of every episode
so stick around for those.
1-888-
EARPOD1.
#EarBiscuits.
Hi, Rhett and Link.
This is Natalie calling from Ontario.
I went on my YouTube Music today
and it told me that I have
listened to James and the Shame
987 minutes, which is about 16 hours
over the course of two songs.
Just wanted to let you
know that I love the music
and I can't wait for
the rest of the album.
Thank you so much for
putting it out there.
Hey, guys.
First of all, love the show.
Long-time fan, super stoked
to hear your full album.
Congrats on it, dude.
First three songs were great.
Love you guys, thanks, bye.
Rhett, in my evening
listening to your song
"Where We're Going" and
bawling my eyes out.
I'm 36 years old, my wife is 35.
I have two boys, 10 and 8.
This past Memorial Day
Weekend she had a stroke
and she's been working
incredibly hard in rehab
to regain the use of her left side
and various mental blocks still.
Needless to say, this has been a whirlwind
and scary last few months.
My days are quite long now,
keeping everything
afloat and moving forward
for my boys and for her,
and this song just perfectly embodies
how much I love my wife
and how much I am still
just so happy to be with her
and look forward to
sharing our lives together
no matter what happens along the way.
I was just so moved and
compelled by this song
that I had to share this with you, Rhett,
and you know how much your
music is impacting people.
Thank you both for
everything you give to us
and everything you share with us.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.